everybody's getting back together all
these casts are reuniting will we see
the militia cast get back together
i am in talks right now with
the right people for that to happen i i
just
i don't see it not happening because of
you know the success on netflix
and it just makes sense i mean i wanted
i wanted to see what moisha would love
to
you know is up to you
what's up mom what's up man hey what's
up dateless in
nothing seattle home alone one two and
three so could there be a reboot
it could be i hope so i would love that
that'd be it i would love that it would
have to be right though because you know
it would have to be right i would we
would have to take some
real time with that to make sure you
know because i don't want to have nobody
disappointed
say that you can look at most especially
black folks and you can say oh there's a
handful like there's maybe 10 shows that
they
that mean the world that you can recite
different episodes and you can talk
about the characters like it's
your cousin or your your auntie and um
this is one of them so you can't mess up
you know you cannot mess around did you
have a chance to
have you gone on netflix and watch any
of the other shows
not yet no not yet honestly i've been
promoting
b7 so much i only had one i had that
chance to watch militia that one time
with my daughter so
i haven't got a chance to check out all
the other shows but i'm definitely going
to
okay i want to i'm going to take you
back we're going to show you
the first interview your first et
interview hold on here we go
a lot of good things has happened to me
since
you know i first started none of this
stuff i never thought would happen i
never thought i was gonna get my own
tv show my own album so
it's been great i'm very very nervous
i'm very nervous
because i don't know how this is i don't
know how the audience is going to react
to me playing
milisha because they're so used to me
singing baby baby baby and
they're not used to me acting as much i
didn't act a lot on thea so
i'm kind of scared about how they will
react with me acting like militia
not that it's a big difference but you
know but still i'm acting other than
singing
but hopefully now when if this show gets
picked up
they'll be calling me moesha
wow you know what
it's crack that girl was so on point
wasn't she wasn't she
yeah what are you thinking
oh my god i just
i didn't i'm so sorry i did not expect
to uh
get emotional just
i'm sorry i don't know what to say but
it's
it's important to say listening to you
say
if this show gets picked up
and it's a classic now yeah
and there are a lot of people who have
classics in there you know what i mean
not a lot of people that have have done
classics yeah yeah
[Music]
i am so embarrassed right now i'm so
sorry kevin
um but yeah what advice would you give
to that girl
oh my god i would i would just tell her
to keep going
keep going yeah and everything is going
to be okay
it is okay yeah louisa no no no no don't
try to stop me daddy my mind is made up
i'm going to college daddy what's my
[Music]
baby
i'm proud of you even though i know you
love your job at vibe i think you did
the right thing
so one of the things we can do is binge
tv and
moisha being on netflix how amazing is
that
i am so blown away by that
like i was braiding my daughter's hair
the other day and we
watched um an episode of moisha on
netflix and she wanted to watch
the episode where moishe met randy
me and and it was just so because i
don't really have a lot of memory of of
militia because i was so young and it
was happening so fast
so to have it on netflix and to be able
to watch
it with my daughter it's just it's it's
just so special for me i also find that
this is there's kind of a gap in
programming
these alicia and girlfriend and
everything that girlfriends and the
other shows are on netflix now
growing up and it was this positive like
of not only blackness but families and
so how important is that for it to be
back
i i think it's i think it's it's super
important i mean because we need that we
need to see that we need to see
black family we need to see um you know
shows that that are you know discussing
real issues and
and talking about it as a family and
handling it as a family
and i think that's crucial right now um
and it was crucial then
you know yeah no but it still plays
that's the beginning
it's timeless yeah you know it is um
we got a chance to spend a lot of time
on set there um do you have a
favorite moment that you remember from
alicia like
one time yes i remember the first
episode um i had to
get very emotional and i didn't know how
because you know i
i wasn't really an actress at that point
you know
i just kind of got lucky but uh shirley
ralph
just you know sat with me and just told
me how to you know find my emotions and
you know she says just be honest just
find something in your mind that
you know and and go there and don't be
afraid to let us all
see it and um that was a special moment
that we shared and you know
that was great and she is such a great
like
people don't understand that cheryl lee
ruff really is like mama she's like she
puts her
everybody yes and she has such a
beautiful spirit
and just a beautiful woman period her
grace just everything about her like i
wanted to be shirley ralph
[Laughter]
so is there a is there a favorite person
who came on that you remember fame
favorite guest star that you always
think about when you think about maori
bernie mac bernie mac was
my uncle bernie on militia and every
time he came to the set
every time he was just a part of the
show it just he just brought so much
life
and laughter and just it was never a
dull moment with him
and i just i just always remember him
saying you know i'm gonna get my own
show one day i'm gonna get my own show
one day and then
kings of comedy and then he got his own
show and you know just
what a great man you know so to be able
to work with him and meet him
and you know experience his energy was
was was a blessing
yeah you know you talk about bernie but
there were so many great folks who had a
chance to come on that show
and it really did it even broke a bunch
of people
you think about all the people that used
to come through and even just the people
who would visit the set
what do you remember about that
see like i said my my memory is uh of
musia is like
it's a little vague but i can tell you
about my angelou
she came and you know i had a scene with
her and i will never forget that scene
she just
her presence just it just me it just
i just i can't even describe it it was
just unbelievable by angelou
and diana vanzant was there once
and jennifer lewis
lewis who's my auntie who's my friend
today so
uh just magical people
magical people issa rae actually spoke
to us and she said that she was
a audience member wants it malicious and
that inspired her to break into tv
how's that that makes me feel i'm
amazing and she's always said you know
beautiful things about you know militia
and how moishe inspired her
and you know she's such a fantastic you
know actress and
artist and you know that's why you do
what you do is to
inspire people that's why i do what i do
so
i love that and i love when people you
know
pay homage and express themselves
because
that always feels good mm-hmm yeah we
got to get i'm telling you love again
with like
well as as east and lawrence get back
together
what was the craziest encounter you
remember from that time because when
militia
finally did it exploded and what do you
remember like the craziest thing about
that time
um i remember uh doing a mall appearance
yeah this small appearance i i was i was
signing a bunch of autographs for
a lot of people you know a lot of fans
showed up but then it got to a point
where
you know i i got mobbed you know and it
was just
it was unbelievable and i felt because
it was the music and it was because of
militia
and i remember going outside and running
you know running into the you know my
car or whatever
and it was a helicopter flying around
you know just like it was on the news
like
so i remember that was like a
[Laughter]
you know i'm not the greatest
storyteller like i said in my words but
i do remember that that was that was
that was interesting
what's a secret you might be surprised
about that you can tell us about militia
they know so much but there has to be
a secret you can tell us about militia
about the show that maybe um
well i can say that
when moisha met brandy
i knew who milisha was and i didn't know
who brandi was
wow really yeah
so as i'm playing militia like i had
the confidence and and everything but
when it
when it got time for me to you know be
myself
i didn't know how to really act i didn't
know what to really
like i didn't i didn't know my
personality you know
was that hard growing up with so in that
bubble you know that was it was very
difficult
yes it's very difficult to grow up in
front of you know the public eye you
know
in front of you know everybody you know
because
when you're a role model you know people
um
you know expect you to be perfect in
everything you do and
you know i was growing up and i wasn't
perfect
i never will be perfect you know but um
but again i don't i don't i feel very
blessed you know to experience
everything that i've
that i've been able to experience and um
i wouldn't change anything
yeah but it's interesting as you say
mention about being a role model because
so many girls you were the first
their age they ever saw on tv and so it
meant so much to them and it you know
especially
african african-american young ladies it
meant everything to them to see you so
that must have been crazy pressure
it was pressure and and i also
appreciated you know
being an example you know because i i
felt like that was um
that was my responsibility being in the
public eye you know it's my
responsibility
to be an example but you know there is a
pressure
that you feel when you feel like you
can't make a mistake
that's a different level of pressure
mm-hmm you know
i really i needed i needed a break from
that kind of pressure
and so how did you get that break
i had a baby at 23.
and so my whole life became about you
know
my daughter and she's an angel like she
saved me and now i'm here to
show her which way to go
[Laughter]
by the way what did she think of the
album and i know she has her own music
so
she does she loves the album she really
loves the album she
she was so encouraging um uh
with me because you know when you've
been gone for a long time you kind of
you know
doubt and worry and you know i was
dealing with all that the nerves and
everything and she said mom this album
is amazing you have to
you have to go on with it this is you
know i love it and she has some
favorite songs on there that almost
didn't make it that i put on the album
because
they were her favorites um and uh
so she's been you know definitely
my musical angel for sure just helping
me through
everything and uh and i'm
you know i'm encouraging her and her
music as well i want her to take it slow
though
because you know again this business is
it comes with its ups and downs so
i want to make sure that she has tough
skin and
and knows who she is before she gets off
you know gets in this business
yeah by the way for the people out there
who don't understand
what would you say was the toughest
thing and how you got old how you
overcame
those hurt like the down times how you
overcame that
um i did a lot of um
journaling a lot of counseling
um a lot of prayer
and um i created a lot
you know i put a lot of my um
emotions into music
you know i use music as a way to heal um
even if i didn't put out music even if i
didn't you know
if i didn't have anything out there like
i still would create you know
but um it takes work to
stay healthy mentally and physically all
of it
okay one last thing for all people like
my
like my child who's not for the first
time you know he's 13 but he hasn't
he doesn't understand it he knows you as
brandy yes
what would you say to all this new
generation
who is going to discover militia what do
they need to know
they need to know that they can trust
this teenager
she's gonna make some great choices
she's not gonna make
every every choice is not gonna be right
but
she's gonna she's gonna try to make the
right choice
and she has great intentions and um
you know she's somebody that you could
follow and look up to
for sure